hey youtubers it's Charlie this week's
Game of Thrones bonus video is gonna be
all about the history of Winterfell and
eat a little bit about the north you
can't really talk about Winterfell
without talking about the rest of the
north just to start let's do a recap of
where we're at right now and what's
what's been going on at Winterfell since
the show has started where we are on the
show right now the Bolton's have control
of Winterfell Tywin Lannister made Roose
Bolton warden of the north in exchange
for his help getting rid of Robb Stark
if you've noticed they actually have
like a little flayed man on top of the
3d model of Winterfell and the opening
credits that's that's why the flayed man
is there because the Bolton's currently
control Winterfell and even though
technically they have controlled the
North politically that doesn't mean they
have the support of the north remember
that funny scene with Stannis and Jon
Snow
Stannis had asked for the support of
Bear Island House Mormon are
traditionally bannermen to the Starks
Lyanna Mormon said there is only one
king in the north and his name is Stark
that's a reminder that most of the north
still only recognizes how stark as their
true leader so right now the Bolton's
hold on the north is very precarious
that's what season 5 is gonna deal with
the Bolton's trying to hold the north so
it'll be really interesting to see how
that goes down most people do not know
that Sansa is still alive like if Cersei
and the Lannisters still knew where she
was they would probably try to hunt her
down and kill her that's why
Littlefinger has been protecting her why
she's been living under a false name
she's the true heir of Winterfell right
now because as we saw Jon Snow did not
take Stannis's deal to legitimize him if
he had taken it most of the North would
have rallied around him but Sansa still
would have had a claim being of more
pure blood so you could have gotten into
like a Targaryen Civil War situation
where people argue over the the blood
rights of succession but I don't think
there's any way Jon Snow would ever ever
fight against one of his family members
so it's a moot point and if you're still
wondering who Leanna Moorman is she's
the niece of jr. Mormo the former Lord
Commander also the niece of Sir Jorah
Mormont here that's where we are on the
show right now there are like eons of
history of the north and Winterfell that
the predate the show the george RR
martin hasn't written yet and a lot of
you are wondering where history on the
show comes from usually what happens is
is characters will talk to other
characters anecdotally about past events
or you'll see them reading passages out
of books
that's usually where most of the ancient
history of the show comes from like like
old man's stories to people telling
stories to other character
there is world of Ice and Fire but
that's kind of an offshoot and it
doesn't get like super specific into
past events it's just kind of
extrapolates based on the stuff that we
already know most of you have probably
heard that bran the Builder is the one
that built Winterfell he's the same
person that's credited with building the
wall after the long night but the
history of House Stark can be traced all
the way back to the high king of the
first men Garth greenhand he's one of
the former rulers of the first men that
a lot of people up in the north can
trace their lineage to just like a
common ancestor it's like Genghis Khan I
think it's something like over 50% of
the people in China have like some
common DNA with Genghis Khan just
because he sired so many children so yes
how stark can trace their lineage to the
high king of the first men but but so
can a lot of other people for example
one of his sons Garth the gardener went
on to found house gardener obviously we
know during Aegon's conquest of Westeros
house Gardner fell in house Tyrell kind
of took their place but the Starks in
general just traced their lineage to the
first men much more so than some of the
other houses which trace their lineage
more to the Andals or say like the
Martel's in the south who trace their
lineage to the Rhoyne ur the house
Starks though you know much more than
say some of the other great houses of
Westeros trace their lineage to the
first men in the children of the forest
most maesters in the Citadel believe
though that Garth was just like got like
a war chief like a typical war chief
that led people across the arm of Dorne
into Westeros the first men migrated to
Westeros using the arm of Dorne there's
a lot of arguments as to who the first
official leader of the First Men was
mostly they just call him the first king
that was about 12,000 years before
Aegon's conquest so there's no promise
that George RR Martin's ever gonna
explore this moving down the Stark line
it's believed that one of Garth's other
sons brand the bloody blade was Brandon
the builders father the only thing of
note that he's really credited with is
driving the giants north from the reach
and driving out a lot of the children of
the forest there's a lot more that's
known about brain the Builder but still
a lot of the history that was recorded
around his time was written by masters
that lived thousands of years after he
was alive so you know you could view
that some of it is conjecture but
generally it you know he lived towards
the end of the Age of Heroes the Age of
Heroes began around the time the first
men signed a peace treaty with the
children of the forest and they stopped
fighting each other
as part of the pack the children of the
forest just took to the forests and the
first men kept to the south most of the
traditions that survived from this time
we've actually we've seen on the show
like a worshipping of the old gods in
the godswood that's what the heart trees
are for the weirwoods then there's the
laws of hospitality that gives into a
red wedding territory that just says
your honor bound to take care of people
that you bring in and feed so you invite
someone in for meal even if they're your
bitter enemy you can't kill them a lot
of people so probably heard the term
kings of winter so that's just the term
given to rulers of House Stark like
rulers of the North that predated
Aegon's conquest by that logic you could
call king Turin Stark the last king of
winter because he was the one that bowed
to Aegon the conquerer that's why
there's no stark blade inside the Iron
Throne Aegon the conquerer only melted
down the blades of people that refused
to bend the knee this is what the Iron
Throne is really supposed to look like
you know the show made it a lot smaller
so you could see there's a lot of people
that did not bend the knee I know
there's a lot of confusion about that
because they said that all of the former
kings of Westeros had their blades
melted down but technically in the books
it's only the kings that did not bend
the knee when Aegon asked them to it was
a situation where he was like you can
either bend the knee or I'll melt you
with my dragons so in and around the
same time brain of the Builder is
credited with building the wall or
starting to build a wall he's also
credited with starting to build
Winterfell and like most big castles in
real life it started with a single
structure and then over time future
kings just added to it there's a lot of
lore that's been generated around the
specific location of Winterfell the main
structure of the castle is the great
keep that's the one that's built on top
of hot springs just you know to keep it
warm naturally it's not the oldest
surviving part of the castle the oldest
surviving part of the castle is actually
the first keep right here but it's in
ruins as we saw in season 1 we did
Winterfell is a really big place so
parts of it and ruin that's one of the
big problems with owning a castle is
that you have to pay to keep it up and
it's expensive as hell the place where
bran witnessed Jaime Cersei twincest
is actually the broken Tower just a
slightly different place but right near
the first keep supposedly the first keep
was built around the time the Andals
invaded so this would have obviously
been it been like much much later after
a brain in the Builder lived the Endel
invasion is somewhere around 2,000 years
after the time of Brandon
builder like I said a lot of this
history was recorded by maesters
thousands of years after it happened
though so you know a lot of the dates
can be fuzzy so if the oldest surviving
structures at Winterfell only go back to
the Andal invasion then obviously the
parts that brain and the builders
supposedly built have fallen into
disrepair or just were destroyed over
time
technically the godswood would be the
oldest part because most of the castle
would have been built around that the
original castle it's most likely that
the location for Winterfell was chosen
for practical reasons like it is in a
relatively central location and the hot
springs help provide a natural source of
heat old man tells a story though that
there is a sleeping dragon beneath
Winterfell sleeping in the hot springs
so it's totally possible that there's a
clutch of dragon eggs beneath Winterfell
but but no one's checked to see I know
everyone wants to see more dragons on
Game of Thrones you know for now it
seems like Daenerys dragons are gonna be
the only dragons don't worry dragons can
change sexes so a couple of Daenerys
dragons could swap from male to female
and they could make with each other as
it right now unless we find more viable
dragon eggs that's the only way we're
getting more dragons so you start to see
like how some of history is problematic
you know built on legends and theories
and some of the dates are conflicting
like for instance the night's king
supposedly that person we saw at the end
of episode 4 from last season in the
history of the series he was a former
Nights Watch Lords commander also
supposedly descended from bran the
Builder so you could argue that the
night's king has a star or share some
DNA with the Starks that remains
unconfirmed that's just a theory but
that all predates the Andal invasion so
there's any surviving part of Winterfell
that goes back that far
it's the godswood the lineage of House
Stark the George R Martin has spelled
out you know per world of Ice and Fire
only goes back about eight generations
back to Benjen Stark
that's who Ned Stark's brother Benjen is
named for who's still kind of missing in
action as of right now some of the other
really big locations of Winterfell that
we have seen though include the Great
Hall that's where everyone eats together
there's the glass garden two crypts
there's the bell tower the maesters
Tower the library tower in the guards
Hall there are gates on each side of the
castle but to the south is winter town
we haven't spent a whole lot of time
there since season one but that's where
we first find Tyrion in the whorehouse
with Roz
that's right south of Winterfell right
near the South gates typically the
population there swells around
wintertime just for practical reasons
times get rough up in the north during
winter so naturally everyone's gonna
like condensed down and around the main
castle you may have noticed it in the
opening credits sequence the last couple
of seasons Winterfell has continued to
burn that's just you know reminder of
where it's at right now like currently
it lied broken the Bolton's are slowly
rebuilding it though so it'll probably
stop burning in the opening credits soon
as much as it was a bummer that Theon
burned most of the place whenever he
sacked it back in season two it was
actually burned really badly two other
times both by rulers of the dreadfort it
was burned by Royce the second and then
later by Royce the fourth but both of
those times predated the Andal invasion
so that's probably why there are no
surviving structures from say like the
time of bran the Builder aside from the
godswood you have to remember that
Winterfell has been around for thousands
of years and there there been numerous
invasions numerous wars so it's no
surprise that it was destroyed a couple
times throughout history and then
rebuilt so the same thing is gonna
happen again on the show so here's my
big question for you guys what part of
Winterfell do you really want to see
them explore more on the show for now it
seems like you know most of the places
we'll see will be practical like the
courtyard the Great Hall and then the
place is associated with lore the Crips
and the godswood those are probably the
most important locations of Winterfell
anyway but it would be nice at a certain
point to get a better tour of the
grounds that would mean they have to
spend more money building said so you
know maybe in a future season who knows
just a reminder that my new Game of
Thrones episode 3 video is gonna post
tonight after the episode airs be sure
to subscribe to get it I'm running a new
round of the giveaway if you're not
already you can also follow me on
Twitter and Facebook for updates on you
know when when videos are coming so
there are links for that in the bottom
of the description so in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
my episode 2 video and you can click
here to learn all about the house of
black and white in the faceless men
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]